president biden is finally gearing up to
take questions from reporters this
afternoon during his first formal news
conference in months
so what should they ask him joe concha
joins us now it's conscious time joe i
asked you yesterday what question you
would ask what is your question still
the same as it was yesterday or have you
changed it for today
oh wow uh well yesterday i asked why the
fentanyl crisis isn't being addressed
it's the leading killer of those between
the ages of 18 and 49 yet we barely hear
anything about it from this white house
i think that would be a good one but i
think today griff i'd love to know why
is it easier to vote in the state of
delaware that's joe biden's home state
he was a senator there
for many many years or why is it i'm
sorry harder to vote in delaware where
biden was a senator why is it harder to
vote in new york where chuck schumer the
senate majority leader
resides and has been a senator for
decades than it is in georgia which the
president compares to jim crow 2.0 in
terms of its voting laws there i'd like
to see him explain that or i got one
more uh can you explain how passing
build back better which would be
trillions of new spending would lower
inflation and lower the deficit sir
specifically how does the math work on
that i'd like to see questions like that
they're not gotcha they're not unfair
and i want to see people sit back and
let the president try to explain these
things instead of asking about donald
trump which i'm sure we're going to hear
about i'm almost positive january 6 is
undoubtedly going to come up or advocacy
from reporters for the filibuster as we
saw in his press conference all the way
back when in march of 2021 but hopefully
we didn't see a preview guys of things
to come during this press conference
yesterday with this question listen to
this from ap's colleen long quote i
wanted to ask about negotiations over
voting rights and to see you know what
you guys are expecting this week and
then what's plan b if things go south
you know to secure elections and make
sure voting access
if the bills don't pass so think about
what we're hearing there that's not a
question that's advocacy right talking
points around securing elections that
already are secure and voting access
that already exists if that happens then
you'll be hearing from you later on this
network i have a feeling oh i'm sure we
will um i also hope that a reporter
asked the president if he should
apologize to those border agents he
accused of whipping migrants when it
turns out that that wasn't the case
the biden administration joe is also
reportedly planning a communications
reset for year two in office they say
that they want him to speak directly to
the american people more often do you
think that that is a good strategy
i don't judge this administration carly
on their words anymore it's strictly on
their actions so when they say oh we're
going to reach out to the american
people more we're going to make the
president more accessible or the vice
president more accessible or we're just
going to have more one-on-one fireside
chats without the fire of course until i
see that happen i'm not going to believe
it very much
and i'm not sure that's going to really
work anyway because it depends on what
they're talking about are you talking
about lowering inflation finally fixing
this supply chain crisis lowering crime
by
flooding the streets with police in some
way shape or form helping local
governments with their budgets hire more
police or the border are you finally
going to fix that problem are you going
to visit the border mr president until i
see actions from this administration on
fixing problems the words don't mean
diddly
well joe talking about the crime crisis
you can see the new york times is
analyzing the surge in murders
you can see here the fallout from the
2020 racial justice protest and riots
could have contributed to the murder
spike police officers scared of being
caught in the next viral video may have
pulled back on proactive anti-violence
practices wait hold on i'm missing
something defund the police movement
nope not in there what do you say soft
on crime policy the fault
yeah the fallout from riots may have led
to what we're seeing now oh yeah i think
so all while the media cheered it in the
new york times ignored it
just like they ignored griff to your
point uh mentioning the fund the police
movement which actually happened in new
york they didn't completely defund the
police but something like one billion
dollars was cut from their from their
budget now we see what's happening right
uh so look i i remember when those riots
were happening those protests were
happening we kept being told by the
media that the cause was bigger than the
virus or something uh and now look 16
cities are setting record homicide rates
they did it in 2021 and it is exactly
because of what happened in 2020. it set
a precedent and from there the bar was
lowered and we see anarchy from new york
to minneapolis to seattle to atlanta to
chicago guys well joe i'm very much
looking forward to hearing what you have
to say tomorrow about the president's
press conference today looking forward
to that in the meantime thank you for
joining us this morning
thanks jim i love getting up early
thanks guys it's really cool we're glad
you do we really are i'm steve ducey i'm
brian kilmeade and i'm ainslie earhart
and click here to subscribe to the fox
news youtube page to catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis